Okay, so this is a question obviously from a rife user. Is it normal for the hammer bulb to get super hot while I sleep with it?
So the hammer bulb with the rife machine is typically used for overnight use. It's a it's a tube
encased in a it's a it's a tomb of a bulb that's
three-quarters inch diameter encased in a maybe three inch to two and a half inch diameter
Plexiglass tube and it's meant to sleep at night with it. It's meant to protect it so that if you roll over it falls out of bed it's not gonna break
But yes, it could heat up typically you got those under the cover is anyhow and it's under the cover next to you
So it's not getting a lot of hair circulation and yes, it heats up
So the older hammer bulbs did not have a hole in the plexiglass and they even thought
warmer
The newer hammer bulbs now have a hole in the plexiglass to release some of the heat
But if you got a cover, I like it so they can still get quite hot
So I mean that's how they're gonna burn you or anything like that, but it can be
incredibly hot in the middle of the summer
So yes, that's normal and there's nothing you can do about it
So just make sure you take it under the hood, it's cool enough a second
Typically you're not going to need problems with it